what you make of will Gooch I love will
Goose I think he's great I think he is
an interesting and compelling breath of
fresh air into the ultra running
Community
um just by way of background I have some
experience in Ultra endurance events
I've done a bunch of hard races over the
years
um so I have uh uh a connection to that
Community I know a lot of people in that
Community have a lot of friends in that
Community
um Wills BFF in in ultra running is our
mutual friend Robbie Ballinger who ran
across the United States has done a lot
of hard things set the record the F the
uh fkt for the central how many laps of
the essential how many miles you can run
around the loop in Central Park in one
day like he's done a lot of crazy wild
stuff and those guys couldn't be more
different uh and yet are the closest of
friends train together race together
they crew each other's Endeavors and
it's a really beautiful friendship that
I I've been sort of privy to to
witnessing and observing I know Robbie a
lot longer than I know will but I
followed will it was Robbie you
introduced me to will originally
uh so I started following will online
and I just
found him to be
so unique as a figure in this strange
little subculture of ultra running
because that is a culture that
historically has been populated with
you know guys that uh you know live in
the van down by the river know how to
grow a nice beard
um it's a granola crowd it's a very it's
a very it's a very in a beautiful way
it's a Grassroots community
uh that has
um
that has uh you know participated in and
helped grow a sport where typically
there's no media coverage there's no
prize money nobody's doing this for
Glory or media attention you pitch a
tent at the starting line the night
before you wake up you do your 100 miles
and you go home and and nobody else in
the world knows what you did except for
you and there's something really pure
and amazing about that and and
and uh and that's sort of woven into the
fabric of what this sport is about here
comes will Goose male model six pack abs
looks a lot more like a rugby player
than an ultra Runner he's got you know
the shaved torso and the uh skincare
routine that he's happy to share with
you he's walking the catwalks he loves a
nice bathrobe and a five-star hotel and
tea Service uh he enjoys the Finer
Things in life good breakfast yes at the
same time
he's an absolute beast when it comes to
ultra running uh
fueled by a desire to make peace with
the early passing of his mother who who
died of cancer and to raise money and
awareness around cancer research he
begins participating in these Ultra runs
uh mostly I think he started doing some
marathons and he he did the the John
o'groats run he did a couple hard things
but then created some self-styled
Adventures for himself ran around Lake
Como and this past summer ran across the
United States no small feat 3000 Miles
Robbie was there every single day
supporting him uh Rhys Robinson uh was
the guy who created the weekly Vlog on
the audacious report which is the
YouTube channel that they have Reese
used to work for me he lived at my house
he created videos for me so I know these
guys really well and it was super fun to
watch will so throw down day after day
52 miles 54 miles 56 miles and do it
with a smile
and a certain flare
and a passion for fashion this guy looks
good
and as hard as that was
there's something inside me that was
thinking
he's kind of making it look easy
and this in turn ruffled some feathers
out in the ultra running Community I
love this I want to know about
this
that you know there's a certain idea of
of of what an ultra Runner looks like
how they're supposed to be and will
isn't will is very different from that
and I think people don't like
different and so
there was a a sort of who is this guy
and what is he doing
um and then on message boards people
started
uh taking shots at him and there was a
little uh movement about whether or not
he was actually doing this legitimately
okay so skepticism around the actual a
lot of skepticism yeah so much so that
one guy flew from the United Kingdom and
showed up they were I don't know where
they were in the middle of the Navajo
Nation or something like that convinced
that Will was cheating
and that he was there to root him out
it's a story that will shares on my
podcast I don't know when this is going
up and I'm not sure when my conversation
with will is going up but
um
and will had to kind of weather that on
top of the difficulty of just actually
competing this very difficult task uh
and so at which he did and he did it
again with flair do you have a I think
it's a British record perhaps it's not a
world record but I think I don't even I
don't remember offhand I could have
looked that up
um I think that was part of what ruffled
feathers that he was going to be the
fastest British guy but there was this
other guy it's like who cares like will
doesn't even care you know he just
wanted to go do this hard thing and
raise money and
um experience it with his friends and
you can watch the weekly Vlog on the
audacious report and see how it all went
down but I respect will
for
his conviction
and his sense of self to just be who he
is unapologetically do you know he
reminds me of Ross Edgley
a little bit uh I love Ross Ross is
great I'm not so much in the way he
looks all the way he dresses Ross is
like permanently in Ross is still Ross
is a lot sillier yeah he's an absolute
animal in the way that he trains uh mad
respect for Ross and and and his
accomplishments I think he's just in if
you see his new one in uh
yes yeah and now he's back in Byron Bay
Training
um but Ross is
Ross's I think Ross has a more childlike
nature to him that's very endearing uh
but yeah similar in that they've cut
their own path in Endurance Sports not
So Much by participating in other
people's races or sanctioned events but
by creating their own self-styled
Adventures what's the endurance
communities response to Ross being
because he did he's for the people that
don't know Ross swam for about 200 days
six hours on six hours off
without stopping right around being
circumnavigated the UK the first man to
ever swim around the UK he has recently
tried twice unsuccessfully in
combination with Jim shock to
complete the longest ever single
duration swim
uh first time in Loch Ness too cold
second time in Italy too hot yeah uh
this African Heat Wave comes in and the
water temperature is 32 degrees the air
temperature is 40 degrees so it's
unbearable anyway
what was the
endurance community's response to this
guy who trains Chris Hemsworth looks
like a bodybuilder crossed with a salty
old Sea Dog but is a always laughing
I didn't see any any uh negative stuff
about him but I wasn't looking for it
either it surprises me yeah I mean he's
a he's a very affable guy
um people especially in Open Water
Swimming can get very particular about
rules and how these things are conducted
there's a whole controversy around uh
Diana nyad when she uh did her Cuba swim
to Florida
some people say she broke the rules it
shouldn't count Etc so there's there's
some Persnickety kind of you know
attitude around these types of things I
don't have a sense of negative blowback
on Ross um maybe there is maybe there
isn't but I think to your point of the
similarities between will and Ross like
Ross doesn't look like an endurance
athlete either he's built like a tank
and yes he trained uh Chris Hemsworth
for Thor he's just an absolute unit this
guy which is not the kind of
uh uh physique that you want to have for
long distance Open Water swimming and
I've told him I'm like why are you
putting on all this bulk you're making
this harder for yourself if you lost 20
pounds of muscle your shoulders wouldn't
get tight you'd lose a little bit of
power in your stroke but when you're
going for uh Ultra endurance that's not
important what's important is efficiency
and your ability to conserve energy but
he is who he is and uh I I love him to
death I just think he's a delight to
watch and I'm always cheering for him
yeah I uh I've really enjoyed watching
Ross his book uh the art of resilience
for anybody that's going through a bit
of a tough time if you've read or
listened to the obstacle is the way
enjoyed it and thought I want more like
a spiritual successor to that book is
the art of resilience from Ross So stoic
Sports Science I think he called it yeah
yeah
um and it's this sort of
semi-autobiographical
Diary of his swim around the UK where he
applies both stoic philosophy lessons
and Sport signs to the narrative
horse and he's a great writer he he's
not a contributor to GQ like he's been
writing for a long time I think he has a
sports science degree
um and he's done a lot of crazy stuff
like he did a log Triathlon like Karen
yeah log swim he pulled a car you know
like he's done a lot of kind of Jack
LaLanne type stunts over the years in
other news this episode is brought to
you by levels one of the single biggest
predictors of how long you're going to
live and how good you will feel whilst
living is your metabolic Health the
single best way to understand how your
daily decisions are impacting your
longevity and Your vitality is by
tracking your glucose this is why I wear
a continuous glucose monitor from levels
it allows me to understand in real time
whether the foods that I'm eating are
having a positive or A negative impact
on my health the levels app interprets
your glucose data and provides a simple
score after you eat a meal so that you
can see how different foods impact your
health and develop a diet which is
custom and personalized perfect for your
body the main realization that I had was
eating cereal at any time of the day
spikes my glucose through the roof but
if I took a walk for about 15 minutes I
could bring that back down I would have
never realized this if I hadn't been
wearing a continuous glucose monitor
right now levels has a special offer for
my listeners by going to the link in the
description below or heading to
levels.link slash modern wisdom that's
levels dot link slash modern wisdom
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that clip with Rich then press
here for the full episode in all its
Glory